and we all love the last word with more
kognito any boxes
Friday morning can't fire what's going
on e uh well there are ships blocking
out the Sun their ships hovering over
Neptune or let's see Titans methane
waters but before we talking about this
game that we've been having so much fun
with this week we've got an awesome
guest joining us this morning part of a
cool cool crew so let's bring her into
the the campfire and pull up her at
Polaris eats that's right all right
welcome to the last word episode number
111 it's another glorious Friday we back
it from the Kerr fire for some more
lunar shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about our special guests so we
gonna get right into it I wonder it was
a lady whose overall passion for RPGs in
the Destiny franchise is truly resolute
within our gaming community whether it
be her super chick dreams or playing
destiny of Japanese she's definitely a
sonification of a hardcore gamer
straight do sing the created most of the
chibi Kim twitch channel and proud
member of the iconic team resolute clan
the queen bee of destiny and a very old
food gardener of salvation
and making her first ever podcast debut
at the campfire of the last word lady
chibi Kim how you do is this oh I'm
doing wonderful good morning guys
I am honored to be on your show
thank you for the intro of it pleasure
to have you we had to get this done
queen bee in there because I could look
at reference any story about my name too
based on the rapper but I did it is
Japanese otherwise you do it okay I am
doing wonderful it's you know we
actually are doing this from work
so it's nice and quiet here than I
thought you know I've never done the
morning podcast let me just bring my
Chromebook here when we can just set up
at work and I'm sitting out here it's
raining and I'm like oh god I've never
done a podcast in my life before so this
is exciting for me that is that is the
privilege we get this morning she's
doing that podcast from work she said
bosses know I got stuff to do
that's why she's queen bee that's why we
want to get to know you a little bit and
I know I asked you a couple questions
but our community wants to know as well
and I asked you one question so I got a
jump on this one early just a quick idea
of like what good you started in gaming
and then I know but I'm gonna let you
say it what we got a game we got to talk
about what's what's near the top of your
favorite games as well so a couple few
top games and how did you get started in
gaming how long you been how long you
been holding up controller oh god I've
been holding that controller since I was
like what Jen remember six cuz you know
my mom gave you insist of Nintendo and
we had out there with Super Mario
Brothers now I just play that for hours
you know and then even years came around
and then you got the Super Nintendo and
that's when I really got addicted to
video games especially RPGs Final
Fantasy three and my personal favorite
that is still to this day is like the
best RPG of all time for me because I
love story the music the characters
they're you know a different endings to
that game and you know I wanted so much
that I still have you know I still have
the original medium PlayStation version
so I have like two and then from there
it was mostly main cast and
and Oh God but you know the kid in me
well I was no I wasn't killed as a team
my dumb but sold those games and our
[Laughter]
stone horse was my jam on the Dreamcast
Oh beautiful
yeah a station Final Fantasy 7
yes oh man we love that one and then
there was a station to Train remember oh
now I remember PlayStation 2 I bought
Onimusha with jean reno like samurai
Resident Evil h3o much PlayStation 3 I
don't remember anything about it at all
except it was plot I'm happy we don't
get the last of us so that patients
that's PlayStation would love text the
fault was similar to spider-man even
when the George Foreman grill but I
missed out on that era and I know it had
to laugh I was on there but I didn't get
that until four came out and that's
destiny walk about it said to myself I
was not gonna buy a Playstation or
because I was not feeling three and when
destiny came out and they show what you
could do go into different planets on
your different ships and arrows and
three subclasses to choose from and
for powers I was like okay you know what
I'm in and so I stopped playing ever
since is hope I come home that's the
first thing I do fire up destiny hmm why
there's a bust knee in the veins man
yeah what what wait he's so addictive to
you why why do you keep coming back
I know great about it mostly when I
played when destiny one came out it was
a tightening so I just loved the weapons
the designs of the armor you know the
exotics yeah that's a good plan it's the
different planets you go on they have
their own kind of aesthetic and work
it's just beautiful
then it feels like am i playing eight am
i playing it mm oh am i playing a pvp
shooter is it's got that nice mix of
everything that I enjoy and then this is
a fashion show there's dress
the shooters whoa cheers that's I don't
know her and that's what got me addicted
to that game because you never know
there's they're always coming in
surprises too usually though for the
worm thing and that was unique cool
forget if you guys remember the one we
had this thing where he had these like
little space herpes that came out of
nowhere
holding your head that was all caught me
from Road that was almost that was right
before rat to the Machine I'm gonna say
right enough to date with like these
little blogs yes the conversation
between Kane and zabala
yes and we and we were just sitting
there reading those like is this gonna
go away eventually cuz I don't
is gonna happen but with it was just
we'll see you at binky so so cool yeah
so I gotta take it back because you blew
past Chrono Trigger and I don't usually
go destiny but I got a I gotta get a
little bit in here so dimension like
definitely for the story as well and I
was just curious like for me one of the
things about Chrono Trigger that I
always but I've never seen anybody ever
do and it's like the team-up attacks so
you had like Crona with his sword and
robo shoot the laser and then frog like
go spinner and like the triple trifecta
attacks and stuff like that and I was
just kind of curious if there's any like
specific attacks that you like the most
and also since it is a game about a
whole lot of time travel which time was
actually your favorite oh let me see
well my favorite attack I think it was
the one with chrono Merle and um it was
either crawl I think Luka and frog
together yeah cuz she was Marla was ice
so Luca was fire and a robo I think they
were all formed this like little tornado
spin and was like it was like a like
fire spin or something like that and
they dealt multiple damage and then
Chronos my favorite was Chronos like it
was almost like a final Dragonball
attack late he was just about this giant
like bomb and it did massive damage
my favorite era was of course um Magus
is past and I love to have gorgeous
that's if you looked and the meat to it
and you know how no you saw things from
his perspective when he was a little boy
and how his sister was going to be I
think she's gonna be sacrificed for
something and and he you know his name
was he at Janice I think she was it was
a boy and came in and they at the time
to it or something like that that game
is this what I liked about that game you
go into the past you affect their future
yeah Lucas mother and how she lost her
legs I know the first time I did it I
wasn't able to put the coat in so you
know to stop the machine from making her
mother wakes I was like oh okay I
thought about that but you know that's
the thing I love the replay value of it
that was something that was kind of
where a Super Nintendo game effect
anything anything you did in that game
and you could make it right and that's
what's about Chrono Trigger and I will
still play it to this day if I could get
my vacation to work on Steam so that's
eventually I'm gonna replay it over on
stream for me I got to get through it
again - you would besties with disco
well this dude right now you are besties
I love it continue
that yeah that's like I don't see how
many people just specifically be like oh
yeah Chrono Trigger I'm like okay we got
to talk for at least a minute but you
know it's ya know it's a class yeah I
got to give you credit because
in right when we do our do I appear now
to do gaming history it comes up it
comes I think what it is obviously like
Final Fantasy the mainstream kind of
thing but Chrono Trigger always is
revered I've never heard anybody say I
dislike it or like its revered so yeah I
got a solution chrome triggers this love
that's just you can't you know one of
those RPG games for its time that was
unique and and and cool and with a great
story and everybody had their own theme
music so I sit there and I listen to
like the mute the soundtrack on Spotify
it's well I love the music for that game
it's so like cuz I can pick up like the
battle and like don't don't don't do I
like I know it's like that like Megaman
dr. Wily's castle is a very epic theme
you know there's a couple like very
specific music pieces that stand out in
Chrono Trigger that like when I play
through that soundtrack again I can just
picture so many things in that game so
easily I love that soundtrack aside from
that one I have lit
I think super Castlevania now you don't
hit my hey go see two for two let's go
and remember how you can make the the
world spin and continue I was it's time
you know so I said I love the Super
Nintendo air because you know less when
games really took off it didn't end up
like Super Metroid that one's like right
up there bumpin next to a couple of the
top ones Super Metroid I got lost in
that game for hours going back and forth
trying to find every missile oh yeah no
yes way too much time on TV you're
absolutely right because on the thing
about Super Nintendo it doesn't get
enough credit it was a it was a change
in the way graphics were I mean they had
mode seven the 3d aspect you had on i
remember games like pilot wings and an
f-zero and just theory because to be
honest i was a sega kid so I always tell
the story like I'm King he actually had
on Genesis I mean I have to be actually
a Super Nintendo first so then I go to
see Super Nintendo cuz he had it early
and I never forget what our first saw it
and I'm like oh this kind of blows I saw
the super Castlevania you know I saw the
way he contorted the the physics with
the whip and the the rotating of the man
unless I said the 3d stuff and all the
end the music the music wasn't attending
is a strange it was Oh standing like oh
yeah I got it listen as a sake kid I
always always been to me a respect so
what it did a lot of classics and RPGs
not for you guys I know you guys
probably look crazy
well how do you want to break it a
little more recent anything else
reference to obviously you know we know
if our core destiny and stuff like that
but um one thing that stood out to me
you know looking over history stuff was
that how important team resolute was to
you and um I guess how did that journey
start and for you to become a regular
clam clam member and um just to see the
support you know with that team because
I really respect you guys so can you
tell us that story about team resolute
GT oh god definitely something you never
forget
okay still best I think it was still
definitely won and um I was they were
stabbed in aisles you know I was
watching trials on Twitch and KJ Hobie
was on and he was doing trials helps
person with up with my friend Pope the
Care Bear yes and I wanted to play with
him so bad because ho he was like
resolute was cold true Vanguard mana
Gator and okay Jane I was like man I
really want to play and head into the
realm I want and I was sorry
tonight it's a play with ho being he was
nicest guy you've ever met even you know
we I didn't go flawless we tried again
and um that's when I knew it was really
nice about it and a conversational funny
as hell guy that's when I said you know
what you don't wanna I was just so
idolized with them they were just cool
this clan and I really wanted to be a
part of it it was trying to figure out
how do I get join the clan so basically
what I did was I just pretty much
austere streams I got more involved I
was asking you know asking questions I
said I would love to play with you guys
and you know I was I got to know I got
to know a couple of them in the clan and
we did a couple of raids together we did
some activities of PBE stuff and I was
like I I was really enjoying it and then
I got to meet the crew Guardian con when
it was in Tampa lining up go in once
you're in you're good you don't go out
yes I don't care how much you hurt on
that concrete floor plant-like looking
gross and sweaty
I met the core I think the clown there
was there
we carried yeah he runs it along with
auntie and monk and I got to meet them
and then I got to meet a true Vanguard
in person he is just of course on stream
- he's really cool once you get to meet
him and I met his wife I met mana Gator
I got to hang out with them I was just
like and these guys didn't know me I
wasn't in their clan that was Oh in
their Baden clan reso house so I worked
my way up from there and then hosted a
so it was reso how they did it was like
like Resolute's like it was many August
of 2017 this was around the time when
destiny too had come out yet but it was
starting to getting ready yeah I got a
message it was wanted me to do an
interview oh my god GLaDOS like no just
the for a job interview answered all
their questions and then when the roster
came out I was getting messages from
like the clan members DJed him in Booker
and it was like Congrats Congrats that
was at work it was like what do you mean
Congrats I was checking my texts holy
good cus cuz I was like holy [ __ ] I made
it for that it's our moment and still
haven't been on my Twitter because that
was the most exciting day of my life
knowing I
actually became a part of resolute and
I'm like I couldn't believe it
I'm excited to this day a couple of my
friends made it as well and oh it's just
something like that you don't you don't
forget and something like that and just
a salty late to still be a part of
family because we're not all about
destiny you know we do you know we do
some other things you know other games
we just thought about having fun I had
for you just to back up a second was
that year did you say 2017 that happened
was that Tampa Bay other words yes I
remember it very well because that again
I cuz you that year was when I'm asleep
that's good yeah I met boxes that was
the one I met him
that was my first so we literally
probably were at the same in the same
areas we were all in this spot that's
crazy
he was 2017 you said that any seven yeah
I remember it well because I remember
why I because it was steady in there
high FY yes I will sit there like oh
okay I'm from Illinois so you know
summers in the Midwest it was yesterday
was like 91 degrees so I wasn't you I
was like I was used to that but when my
ass landed in got that Airport that
humidity hit you right in the face there
was so thick out there it's just even
wasn't it back for I guess last year's
in 2019 when we were out there my wife
and I went to Universal for heart we
made it through half a day we did the
two Harry Potter stuff that was the
things we wanted to hit man as soon as
the Sun got out and it's just I'm like
no I'm just swimming back to the car
through the air just so humid off true
it's Joe
yeah you know fun think about that
I remember also when the convention
ended was that movie KJ homie was there
- yeah we invited us all of us out to
eat a restaurant remember it was called
I thought that was really nice and we
all got together clan mates friends and
we all got there and we all got a nice
big meal together which was so cool
and that's what I knew did you know
these guys more than just evil clan
mates that enjoy testing they were like
a huge freaking family so before I
really loved about that moment it was
after to come and it was nighttime and
it was really nice mm-hmm very cool very
cool I think there was a he was it was
like a downtown meeting or something
afterwards yeah there was it was a bug
downtown as for Tampa no no no no we
were saying downtown but here the
fairgrounds and there was like the
winged place that we hung out with like
the like the pre first night but then
after the con because it was two nights
right it was two days that one yeah so
after the second night there was a bar
not told if I was like probably 10
minutes away I think because it wasn't a
bar but drive and I meet like half of
the convention ended up in this bar and
the outside and stuff I remember doing
that after that was really cool just I
don't know that is one of the things I
mean Resolute's very special for you
which is awesome and it's rare to hear
people talk about like you have friends
you have acquaintances but if you're
gonna call somebody family that's that's
something special that's awesome because
they were super they were super nice to
me they didn't know me at the time but
it was very open and welcoming and I
really appreciated that and I was like
we did a lot of you know things together
and this day you know we're taking in
new people no I learned from him and I
passed it on to the new clan members
like hey you want to do something else
you know let's have some fun and you
know I see Watson
Chet and I see you know he joined
resolute saying here 2017 I believe and
and with him and we do we do a lot of
crazy stuff together when it's iron
banner we get the gang together and what
cool is good let's go crucible together
they're just regular crucible and that's
the thing I'm mostly you can destiny a
little bit of both okay ve and PvP okay
love PvP more because I just love like I
love the weapons their weapons I use a
lot it's a mixed bag somebody's okay
waffle telephone bleep yes but I will I
got the crucible forgotten why would
last it even though it got did still a
decent gun cuz I like using um honestly
I'm known for as you can see in my logo
and shade grant I know it's it's nice
range is like a little three tapper to
the head what about that gun I just love
using it because it's a nice design it's
got the UM cute little bunny rabbit on
there and I said it's gonna be my good
has a question about the colony please
comment I was gonna get that too as well
I love the colony alright I use colony a
lot so because that thing has little
spiders you shouldn't walk I can do the
sound like choo-choo
you can fool one terrorist go poop
flying in the air oh good a lot and I'm
using it to get
that care was done so far I said used it
in banner I have killed 86 guardians
with it yes unhappy people when they
heard that noise just to get that quest
then and all because I use colony I love
it mmm gotta respect it it's it has a
reputation yeah I hear that thing I'm
just like really really go on tracking
robots now come on I'll be the concept
of it it's cool like that I really like
that because you know it crawls and it
chases you meaning I don't have thumbs
up so yeah she'd be happy cuz I hate I
hate that thing has like it's not long
now
countdown take the last like eight or
nine weeks that are left of this thing
and mountaintops still gonna be running
around let play control match it's gonna
be there forever I'm sure but just for
reminding me I gotta go ahead I got paid
I gotta go ahead pre-order for next
destiny installments oh we got it oh and
also Thank You Watts by the way for
dropping these little nuggets and loving
this also apparently a one greedy with
the heavy sorry time here we go it was
iron banner last week right and I was I
switched over I mostly play on PC but I
I missed my um ps4 buddy so I switched
over to console as I was like come on
let's go play some banner and so we are
on a hot streak we were winning a lot of
games and of course I had the colony
okay so anytime every round came I was
looking at that clock I was gunning for
that heavy that was like let me get the
heavy cuz you know I need to get both
grenade launcher kills
I was gonna say I had no shame when I
was going for the mountaintop no I was
like I would nudge people out of the way
I was I was bad I was going from
mountaintop I had I was I was terrible
I'll be honest though yeah legit full
day like that no something about that
I'm probably gonna miss because I don't
know if they're getting to it like that
in the future
the amount of time I spent with breech
load grenade launchers like fighting
lion and malicious birthright and stuff
like that mm-hmm I like them so much
more than I ever thought it would have
what I was done some people hate him but
I was like the fact that I practiced so
much using them I'd like I enjoy them
all mix them up like fighting lion pde
if you need like void kills just like in
its premiere ammo and you never run out
I like fighting lion kind of that's a
fun weapon and I don't think it gets as
much love as I think it should yes a
good partner I'm bad with it it's like
fire it goes boom boom you got it you
got to be direct with it you know you
gotta know like angles something like
that and that's like I am so bad with
that I rarely use it but I will use the
crap out of the colony that is oh that's
definitely quality one well we had a
couple things happen in the game whew
yeah Tuesday we knew was gonna be big
and I know we even talked last week on
Friday I don't know if it was afterwards
or during but it was just basically the
idea that we knew moments of triumph was
coming and there was no announcement
zero but it was 7-7 we're like all right
it's all gonna happen apparently at once
and damn did it ever um so I wanted to
start just asking you guys when we got
the first piece to drop for moments of
triumph what was the piece of moments of
triumph that got you excited the most
because we've got so I'm just gonna list
them off so you guys can pick a couple
we got the new t-shirt we know we got to
earn our triumphs for that we get the
raid ring in emblem got to go
the old five that are leavin got the
sparrow
we got the title we can go after and
stuff like that so I wondered like when
they drop the moments of triumph info
specifically what was just like I'll
dude I have to have that what hit you
guys chief
all right actually good question what
exciting I can always get this shirt
because um I'm I think I'm just way from
that so that's not a big deal but I want
that ring fit my finger I want it it's
like if you like when I saw that I was
like that is so badass we are trying to
get our a team together so you can do
all hi will
we're in me too hard but the other
reason I want
I've only completed I still do not have
1k voices and I still don't have an air
hello I got Anarchy recently actually Oh
voices and Tara barred the - I'm missing
I knew I don't have that either that one
is not really highly sought-after those
I don't think people are missing too
much though yeah any of those so that's
also another reason why I want to do
these rates because I they said they
were farmable now yes oh yeah so that's
another reason why I want to do all five
of those rates
oh my chances are probably getting those
exotics there and they were at a lot
better so yes yep that is my dream so I
was so excited said we're gonna do these
rates so not only like get that ring but
I can also get those exotics nice spam
huh yeah what don't you like for me
let's go laughs this shirt looks good of
course it should always looks good
for me it was the it was the best mask
you look like some Louie Vuitton with
the chocolate but it's the one with the
glasses on there were three classes but
yeah I think it'd still be and what
would the classes and he got the UM know
what you call it it has there's a black
one with the tricorn and then there's
like the
and one padded was hilarious him a
little moment patch or the yeah I was so
busy it hit me where I need but I do uh
for me it was the
honestly just like the shirt I like the
the blue gold aesthetic of it and for me
it was just one of those I went through
and clicked I was like - and of course I
got to go after the mm xx title since
you know I got the first one year and I
grinded the hell out of everything to
get that title last I was like I got to
do it this time and honestly it the the
title this time I would rather do like
twelve different activities didn't grind
until I'm blue in the face for like but
one last season was just more grindy
this one is just go do a whole bunch of
different stuff and I like how they set
this up as a way to hey go experience
all the stuff before it leaves yes I'll
talk about that a little bit later but
all these raids are gonna be leaving
which was some people were like is
scourge leaving you always kind of
confirms it now because it's included
yes yeah to make sure you to go do all
of those raids but it was it's just
really I like how they're doing it I
don't think even if I'm gonna be able to
buy the raid ring but I don't think I
could buy it I don't think it's a
hundred and twenty-five dollars and I'm
never gonna I'm not gonna wear that ring
it's not like I don't wear jewelry
anyway vagabond oh yeah he's in here
Billy I'll come on get that gold chain
hang it from your Oh what's up I got my
bling in here come on I'm not like the
bling sheet no I will say though the
raids the fact that they threw the
cosmetics in there and like when you
finish spy it they put it on the one
that everybody doesn't want to do the
luxurious toast the emote is guaranteed
from spire be like we know you all hate
fire but you got to do it one more time
if you haven't you got to do it one more
time and it's only normal it's not that
bad but the fact that you're going to do
it I was like that's kind of beautiful
no again I that doesn't take away for
the fact and I don't have terrible 1k
voices
and anarchy well it's pretty moot at
this point like anarchy you can grab
that boss over and over especially to
get like another character of the
checkpoint you could probably flip him
in and out over and over and just work
on that which is really nice that they
set that up that way since that one's
gonna be live in 1k voices yeah I gotta
find people who want to run last wish
but okay Anna anarchy is gonna be grand
able for a lot of people which is good
because it's it's a fun gun to use yeah
fun Brent wish I could check it out okay
we've got a grant that's all it is based
on the criteria of what Underwood we'll
get to it when yeah you guys did the
Bungie store get any extra money on
bungee day by the way from you guys did
you drop anything in there
oh I did not have wisely as you know
bills but I got paid wait oh I really
want that um I don't know if it's too
late to get that emblem it's like a it's
like a it's almost like that of a
Nintendo esque you know you know you
know the 8-bit like heart you're talking
about the red one yeah yeah so that one
that's a separate piece that they did
and it was a direct donation of $25 or
more or in you the Bundy Bungie
foundation destiny to emblem and that's
that 8-bit heart I like that one too
that's a really really cool emblem and
gets you a little red balloon ghost I
love that one and I also want to get
like he said one of those masks mm-hmm
so cool but it's freakin sold out so
don't wait quick yeah well and I
couldn't get him right away and I was
asking I was like hey sis can you give
me three bucks because I think this mask
and I want and it's so cool know what I
wanted to get like me but you want to
keep ones where and I got back on they
were gone oh yeah some of that stuff
went quick like just the Bungie day
20/20 shirt just kind of their emblem
with the swords around it I
that too and that was gone by the time I
got to it some of that stuff went so
fast which is yeah a bummer because it's
only available for a week so I'm pretty
sure once it's gone it's gone which is
end of unfortunate crap I was like man I
don't know when they're gonna have him
back and did I miss out the emblems were
really cool there I can't describe it
but there was one that's greyish oh oh
for the moments of triumph oh yeah yeah
those were really cool they looked
really cool and I wanted those this you
gotta give it to Bungie when it comes to
their marketing Oh sell absolutely
after this what did it pillars what is
trim they know how to sell merch and
just products had generally excellent
yeah so there was like the it was the
purple kind of starburst emblem and then
he talking the more the darker like
almost the white starburst with kind of
the mostly a grey background it's not
the one you're talking about
mm-hmm yeah those two are so
cool-looking the emblems the sparrow
looks pretty sick too it's weird the way
it takes shaders but it is pretty cool
and we get a ghost's we get a traveller
ghost yes yes I'm like looking that I
love how they took the perspective
picture where it's the ghost just zoomed
in right from the city and those last
cities below it but it was like I know
that's not the actual traveller because
like little pieces that are floating or
weird maybe playing with us there for a
second but yeah like the fact that I
knew they had to say something about it
but it was just it was weird the last
week we got nothing and then BAM here's
everything
mmm you so crazy because we all thought
we had them or last week we just like
it's so strange for them not to talk
about it you know right you know at
prior to the but you see that week
before we get a heads up or some police
at least mentioned that it was coming it
wasn't even mention lat yeah you know
they would have something under Twitter
and they would have like this quick
maybe 10 in the second and showing off
the triumph and the cool stuff that they
had I was like oh no nothing no no um no
announcements no stay tuned oh they hit
us what they're like here you go want me
to try do this okay Wow and literally
they gave you a lot you do so much oh no
son infinite this is the swansong for
half of the directors they're like
alright go go play everything now one
thing that threw me and this is just
like again where it's like they're
always really good about but if they
would just choose the right word there
would be a little less controversy when
they said uncapped rewards ah if you
change that to unlimited rewards there
is no question as to what that implies
but uncocked am like can you go higher
power level and it only took like people
say no it's just like the dungeon where
you can grind it over and over but it
was like just change the word and I
wouldn't even said it mmm anybody else
am I just crazy like I mean does the
uncapped make anybody else like even for
half a second go maybe or is it just
like I'm the crazy person I kind of
thought that wait who's like okay what
do you mean by that
[Laughter]
yeah it was it was interesting verbage
you know um you know for me it's just
what else things that once we got
clarification Oh what it was you know I
was like you know what this is cool
because you know let's be honest you
know raids from Bungie I feel some of
the best content in gaming to be honest
you know the phrase don't get enough
credit by them and to see such a small
percentage and a part of the nesting
population play it you know to now to
get this crowd trying to get rewards
it's forcing people to get in there at
least give these things a shot if you
want this merge and I just think their
whole like you said she liked their
whole marketing department the way they
infuse these little rewards and stuff
that's tied into playing our game and
completing our game and getting an
exotic and do is it makes you it's a
good time it feels and I like the fact
that you you can't get this stuff you
just can't buy it unless you do it in
and bungee it are masters of that again
just such a great community and I love
these little things it's it's cool like
I remember like we talked about that
same arm Guardian con that we all went
to you know 2017 it was just really cool
because when we went there you started
to see people with their moment of
triumph sure yeah it's a it's a bad it's
a badger like you know he plays this
game like she plays that game it's it's
it's it's just cool it's so cool of
every aspect about it I missed out on
getting um that one I think it was the
solid blue shirt with the yellow right
it was a band with the one year I'm
trying to book oh you had the burgundy
with gold yes then you had the boom and
the light like dark blue with light blue
and wasn't it like the eight symbols of
like the stuff you
to have all of them because I was that
moment wasn't it the first trying to
remember right I was like it what right
yeah dark blue shirt with like almost
like neon blue yes on the front of it I
think that's one of them
that was a lot of arm taking King stuff
if I remember right that one oh yeah I
never got that shirt I just got the
burgundy and gold and they think the
another one was alone culture yeah white
nickel oh the only two that I have the
reason I didn't get those moment of
triumph shirts before was and that's
time when I was playing destiny
I was solo and I really didn't know a
lot of people and so I was like I was
like there's no resoluteness yes before
the resolute isn't alright about destiny
was the fact that you could play with
people all over and it was fun because I
said I would be bummed about it I had
anxiety issues around people in public
oh it was just for me way to escape and
just and with other people that shared
the same passion as I did about the game
and just up there and enjoy and have fun
and that's what really helped me open up
he when he can't um we came to destiny
because I was like oh people up Inlet
like me that really enjoyed this game
and you know dude that do strikes and
things like that and just found and Chad
you just have fun and and that's what
kind of helped me open up because I was
not much of a talker I you know kind of
kept to myself a lot but then when this
game came it really opened the door for
me and it helped me feel better there at
being and talking to people I mean
that's one of those little things that
people don't realize and and that's
probably and honestly like and think
resolute for being like one of the
positive places to be because you found
a good clan that you know
just like as you naturally interact with
them more everything seems to get better
and those are the those moments right
there are what makes this community what
it is those are the ones that really set
everything apart because you could have
bumped into a bad clan it could have
been a bad experience and you could have
fallen off the game but you like saw
cool clan they lived up to your
expectations of being really nice like
warm friendly people and now look at you
now and we got like we got you on a
podcast like this is amazing awesome he
said I could have said anybody it's like
the the the sheer amount of friendships
I've made because of this game it's it's
truly one of the best communities it
really is yeah it's just the positive
things they do and stuff like that no we
went a little rough stretch you know
recently you know say but what of it is
positivity
I still feel people doing the right
thing and it's cool like just to hear
your story cheap Wow
you know how excited you were for being
a part of part of resolute and stuff
like that and you know and having those
moments with the Klan and being able to
play with people and get out of your
shell and and talk to people it's really
cool to see it it helped me get out of
my shell and Here I am you know talking
to you guys and I know perfect I get
home for work Friday three day you know
two-day weekend gum would be playing
destiny friends I'm hoping supposedly we
get together at the Klan and we're gonna
do all the rates you know that should be
fun and that's the thing you know I've
been with destiny during the highs and
lows but one thing that I still enjoy is
just playing with my friends gosh and it
P be a tea or PvP or private matches
we're always down to have fun and I I
don't take it serious no it's a game to
me it's more than just a game and I'm
just in there just having fun as well
one thing I love about that game it's
just being with the team of here oh oh
two or one be one you know I enjoy it
that's one thing I love about the game
just have so much variety and you're
playing with other people know one thing
destiny has going is their team and um
playing with the friends and I worked a
week together and have a good time yeah
absolutely absolutely completely agree
it's the friend game yeah it was but I
was like a little period and I remember
he said it was the friend game
it didn't go positively at that point
when he said it cuz I think that's he
was in a bad place
yeah right to the essence of the leader
let alone it's this is Frank's game this
is what it's about those connections I
just remember that line specifically
it's funny yeah well if you're gonna be
playing this weekend they definitely
gave you a lot of stuff to do this week
like holy crap I logged in on Tuesday
and man
so to start before we get even to like
quests and new things the director
changed and it wasn't like hey we get
one new ship on the expected plane of
Titan Bam Bam Bam
we got tightened we got mercury we got
Mars pyramid ships are everywhere so uh
as you guys can see in the background of
the podcast I felt like throwing at
mercury yes that one's my favorite
because it literally blocked out the dam
so on yeah thanks to that's my favorite
because I went there during the quest to
get the eyes the savathun and when I
landed at mercury I was like oh there is
this huge pyramid and I'm looking across
from the White House and I could see
like also whitening no coming from it
Allison knew like uh okay
this is wine I'm just just gonna here
just to collect eyes nothing than
unusual and then when I went to IO ships
I looked up and I could just see ya and
was so cool that Titan I didn't
see too much and tighten but once they
struck out to me the most was mercury
and enough yeah mercury and IO and just
just that giant pyramid and the pyramid
ships on aisle just flying by I tried to
make out see if I could see anything in
there because that that's just so cool
I'm all nervous at the same time because
you know he said we get close to finding
out what happens next
going with still doing the thing or of
course Arison drifter and how that's
connected so she's very very by the way
can we can we comment on that tis what
she's very she's very rough with him
well yeah are you surprised it's kind of
a fitting term for him it's just the way
she I've never seen eros like that like
she's been through so much crap in kind
of a week like literally like down
through hell changed half lake has a
third eye for somebody to be like the
weasel Kennedy on with like the whole
you know his whole gambit crazy stuff
what he's doing and now we know like
gambit and all the the moats seem to be
tied to the darkness and the pyramids
and all this stuff and she's just like
this says some base of what probably
broke her so if like he's messing around
always seems to be goofing around and
she's just dead serious and just deadpan
to him to just absolute yes it's
beautiful to watch like it was just like
oh yeah oh yeah I just thought it was
funny I would just I was like yeah she's
really and just I think the eros
character is just really evolving and um
you know with the story and you know
even the interactions with safale you
know those two we would say would never
on the best of terms that he would never
really trust her I think the only point
she really had a great eye was a
acceleration would be at core right but
you know I would say with arms of Allah
specially
this particular week you know when him
you know the pull-up he came through
didn't kill you huh did he kill you okay
after what he was just weak
it gives alone just boxed out man but he
boxes done you out a transman my god no
secret ribs yup same thing Zavala killed
me too yeah I had to watch the symbol
for negotiator I was hilarious when that
happened to I was just like what just
happened why why am i dead
cuz it's so fast and I'm like dude can
you not like check the coordinates make
sure there's no other Guardians before
you just like pop in and just boost me
out of there wow that was that was
amazing but I was gonna say you like to
another point there was that cinematic
at the very start of the season even
like Zavala reached out was like hey and
like actually grabbed her and was like
hey like be careful or something he had
that like almost touching moment with
Eris and I was like what is happening
right now between these two it's it's
they haven't had anything remotely like
that interaction probably ever so that
was actually really cool to see mm-hmm
absolutely watts is like I saw a video
me like I'm just gonna take a couple
steps back you live slowly fine
definitely a class really awesome mm-hmm
yeah so this week we had pyramid ship
show the one on I will say the one on
tight and you can't go gotta go hunting
for the right angle to see it even if
you go over to the rig and kind of go
over to the back a little bit and wander
off the beaten path you might even have
to go there like an adventure but the
way it looks directly at you and is like
this far over like the oceans of methane
it's when you get the right look at it
it I mean this is blocking out the Sun
is one thing but the fact that it's just
like looking right at you is kind of
scary
hominis yeah so like the Titan one was
pretty cool too but we have two things
do you guys want to start with the idea
of the exodus or do you want to start
with our other friendly neighborhood
tracer April
to install G that gtp
got the tracer all right it's incredibly
fun it's like it's almost like one night
when I completed the quest and and I got
the catalyst did she get that catalyst
on there yeah I was I was secretly
testing it out in crucible you know I
was doing some you know I have it PvP
just make sure that thing is insane
No so you guys went to yours because not
everybody's as fast as you what does the
catalyst to let him know I think it's
like oh nice
I haven't even haven't even tested it
out for that long but I remember what it
does I dunno like I said cuz I was I was
playing with it late last night
um middle night so just doing some tests
I didn't really get to fully check it
out but I will say that it freakin melts
now the best way rather than just using
it in long spurts some people have told
me if you just you know do like
short-short
Earth's there's a lot damage mmm really
does you really end in when you want to
go for the UM bring them into light
those little spheres that's when you go
for it but in short bursts it's pretty
deadly and you just grab that sphere and
you only got like a few seconds and are
usually in crucible and when you get
that shield on you can just run man it
just run through people it's like having
your own like personal bubble but that
people run through it you know get
killed that thing is yes and say yeah
this is gonna be fun to use in trials
the thing is my favorite I gotta give it
to Bungie this season when it came to
the Lord
and then this yeah my face
big exotics you know the really fun when
I got
uh-oh grenade launcher whoa I love do
what is what this vote this thing is way
way cool I love that one
oh I started to say I love both of them
if you yes like having me to choose
between my kids which I don't have I
can't I can't because I love both he's
like can I please just use two exotics
this season they're both glorious oh you
have your trace rifle just use that for
most enemies Chuck the grenades out
there come on just at some point let me
play with three exotics that'd be so
much like that would be that would be a
home
yeah mode or some like I'll say yeah
that would be oh my god that would be
chaos but pure weapons only but all you
could use exotics in every slot on you
just exotics only all exotics
you know like a Vatican can you imagine
can you imagine else your character if
you could equip multiple exotics like
you could have some you good to have
your dune marchers on for your Sprint's
along with like you know masculine quiet
one and armamentarium and then go ahead
and just have good it's like you could
make some crazy kit I would put some
point here you would break the game but
a percent but just think you know like
it's one of those like end of a season
or like you know one of those end of the
years when they used to do a rainbow
mode yeah something stupid like that for
like you know end of a year thing I
think that'd be just something hilarious
to do if they ever sunset exotics that
would probably be a good way for them to
easy you look forgive him to not listen
to this bed tell a joke I just
Givi the joke is that a Luke I feel that
whatever he suggests stuff that like
literally the next well it'll come up
and then I got a deal with him but his
suggesting that Bungie actually
implements so we don't want to put that
energy after what is good but he'll be
to your point you guys played on yeah
this season it's really it's really been
tremendous I mean like like Cheney said
it best like the exotics have been
phenomenal
but when I when I seen you know I don't
have it yet but what I've seen at effigy
I'm just like Howard who thinks of this
like like bungee or world class not only
with the weapons and in the way to gun
shoot but design right like yes of this
dropping us fear and then this fear
becomes this arm that you can slam
people with you can slap and then also
use it as a mini energy field that gives
you health and it just did the
possibility as a warlock pair this thing
with devour and then that Byfuglien oh
you'd you are gonna be a force to be
reckoned with the hour works really
really well with that thing shop shout
out the NIM boy had a nice video out the
it is man the clips that I'm seeing with
this thing and I'm just like wow this is
pretty pretty amazing stuff pretty
amazing synergies so near shot the
cactus I think he even put it in he took
it through last wish I believe of course
just excited pause he said I think um a
couple of stand now he's sure she was
like stand oh yeah I mean just like if
you had two people just walking through
you're just probably melting ads as you
go yeah yeah fault he said it did well
yep certain boss straight DPS is not as
much you know saying I can do with there
and melt more gas per se yeah yeah so
it's like other thing but it just it's
it's phenomenal and I wanted I know we
spoke about this you know kind of
pre-show but and it's early but um I
gotta I gotta ask y'all like you know
how many weeks in we will place this
week this is alive
this is we're friends all right oh it's
like it's like a 15 week season word
just so we'll darting life right yep
it's fine
so already this is a chatter I'm seeing
in the community I just want to bring it
to y'all week 5 of season of arrived
right we could already throw season of
the worthy in the bushes we we can all
agree season over the worthy listen is
not even we not even gonna discuss in
comparison I never even bother to finish
it exactly there you go right
so my question
hell's like they're not so I guess like
people are now comparing it like this
versus season of Oakland right never had
menagerie yeah you know a lot of stuff
going on and people are saying already
season of arrivals is better than
opulent so to this whoa okay TJ let's
break it down break it down I want to
know why I wouldn't the why's it better
already
okay so I really like how they have
their own bro system set up and I really
love that you can what's a little
decoder you can pick fake pick which one
you which one you want and oh I was
performing for you got rolled gnawing
hunger or you feel like you want to go
for you know that they give you all
these cool options and then
so you can focus it out and then when
you take it to there and your armor I
love how you can do that or Night Watch
I like scout rifles scout rifle person
know I could just go and do you are
apparently yes I'm a scout rifle fiend
but the balut itself the loop pool is a
lot better pulls on maybe you can so the
decoder and I really love it I can hear
the drifters voice and it's hilarious I
go front change in you right
he's hilarious and you know what when he
said I'm like master Rahul but better
and it's better you know yes I have so
many engrams that I'm still decoding I
get to decide whether I wanted to be
focused on recovery or whether I want to
focus in on you know in selected things
like that I really like this season it
gives me a lot to play around with
different loot pools you know if I give
a prime I give a prime but if I get
regular purples
I don't go to the crypto anywhere I just
building him mean but season has been a
lot of fun and I really enjoy so
enjoying public events so you know I can
get some more of those in engrams
because right now I am almost finished
the season I'm sitting it season 83
oh I never got done this quick before
you know I had way like I said last
season I only stopped at season 25 and I
didn't care for the last season but this
was just like but she's like you know
what
Oh nuts what you want fun because you
know we got the next thing coming and
that's I really liked about this one and
do you guys do you guys think the
the knowledge of beyond light stasis and
that everybody's really optimistic about
that is adding to season of arrivals
mm-hmm do you think it's making this one
feel better because we know there's such
a bright light at the end of this tunnel
I'm not knocking this season right I
have a couple issues with it but I'm not
knocking this season but I was just kind
of curious if you think that's like
adding do you want to know my knocks
against the season and go for it so one
is the world loop pool with the vendors
mmm if you want to go and try and like
hey I've got tokens since Apollo let me
go throw a couple of those in see there
are 30 weapons in there and say I just
need a piece of armor you're never gonna
get it oh no
as you were leveling up you're like hey
let me I need a help or something like
that you're trying to go through there's
so many more weapons and that's why they
it's a weird thing that they did because
I mean I so the umbral engrams are I
guess the counter to it because you can
really focus in on those I know but like
if you're late but now it is weird and
we said it before it's like the world
loophole like hey you know you're
powerful gear or whatever that you're
gonna get from checks or whatever I go -
accent I get it not hungry I'm like I'm
surplus that like it's yeah feels weird
but it also has get non weight
non-related means but also like it's
really really hard to get armor from
those because there's I mean if there's
35 things and 30 are weapons your chance
to you know turning your powerful
bounties or whatever when you're
leveling up and get a piece of armor is
really low right now so if you need
armor it does seem harder to get those
types of things
the focus man you only have a certain
number of those right but you got the
option yeah think about that one more
like I said I just go we're gonna let
him finish if we go with a it's like the
bigger one and this is again and now I'm
gonna say this with a giant asterisk
caveat whatever you want to say on the
other side let's go
so when it comes to this season as we
know the fall is coming we don't know
what the scale of stuff is gonna be but
like when I sit there and I have two
night watches but match two night
watches from drifter for reissues this
is land this is like this is the buffer
season it's like I don't know for sure
I'm gonna give them like benefit of the
doubt hopefully there's a lot in the
fall but the the reissue roles that I'm
now earning are are a giant question
mark that I really want to know how the
fall is gonna work because the reissues
now when I'm getting duplicates of you
know my not hungers or duplicates of
Nightwatch and I'm getting the same
things I had before well that's that's
my worry is the reissues at this point
so that's one of those that makes me
wonder season was really awesome
honestly the way they're doing the story
missions every week makes me go in and
play and do interference contact public
events is a better public events and
there's a lot more going on you got like
the blooms over here with like the
little mini champions you're dunking and
you can get the heavy mo when you get
that upgraded there's so much more
interactivity to the public events you
only have to do it twice a week you
don't have to just sit there and grind
forever and then you get to go to a
story mission which while there's only
three there's enough variety in there
and if you do them solo there o times so
I mean there's a lot of great things to
it but if you're gonna compare it to
opulence you could go I want this gun I
want a piece of you could go so specific
and I will say we have the story
missions that are cool we have a public
event but we don't have like the sundial
or the menagerie or do we don't have
that that scale of an activity that
wasn't an opulent I'm not saying it
wasn't but we don't know that we do it
menagerie was the bit the best of all is
oaken saying so we are not missing if
and again this is the dream list like
this the story narrative is cool it
looks seems like it's building to
something awesome public event is an
upgrade but it's still a public event
know like if we start doing those three
same missions and stuff like and maybe
it's the fact that you run Menagerie
over and over menagerie is the
impossible bar but it looks like it's
one of those that like that if they
could somehow squeeze
the story missions and like in an
activity like that in that would be like
the dream seasonal stuff and I know
that's a lot to ask for so I get it but
II what seem prophecy says hi hi hi you
know Jean yeah
remember the coolest newest we just go
ignore privacy that is prophecy boy
you I thought I was tough and I'm I'm
actually on your side of the argument
not to give arrivals the title Jessie
yet but I got to say the way arrivals is
starting and we'll five weeks in like
you said it's its own pace now it I will
attend to his point team menagerie was
special yeah six player activity and
focusing down to what he's talking about
down to the little minutiae of exactly
what you want that that introduced the
focusing right i debuted that kind of
stuff sir if from that and one thing
that he set off off air that we all
flock that we didn't talk to you talked
about just yet was um see the Ovilus
also had a rape we gotta remember so
they they have Carlos ro which I still
haven't done I need to do a smile for it
I'm gonna get it done anymore wearing my
rings blanket yeah exactly so you know I
understand that I will say though eat I
don't think there were many story beats
like me for menagerie like the narrative
has been better this year for sure yeah
it was a little not weighted mean we did
have crown of sorrow true they have a
full-blown raid and we had truck do we
have triumphal and jujuy nom yep
uh yeah that was good try yeah tree hall
came with menagerie I feel like those
were at the same time yeah I would that
seemed about right
look it's opulence is is definitely like
I'm never gonna disrespect
like obviously I just want to see where
this go but right now it's no it's it's
got some force to and it could be like
the the season and like the point I'll
make to defend arrivals is the way the
world is changing
yes have that love a next level like you
log in and you see the ships over the
planet you go into IO and you see these
things take what's going on and I will
say to chibis point
this is arguably even though we're not
had the better system arguably every
weapon whether it be legendary newly
introduced between the guillotine you
know arm hollow words I'm using right
now is just beast like every single
weapon every exotics you know with a
horde and now effigy man like this is
probably the I understand your point
with the loop pool with the with the
reassuring you get absolutely we ain't
gonna defend that you know say oh they
they they gotta fix they got to clean it
I'm widget it um I just feel like this
is probably the best loophole I have
been excited about it's just weird
like I I'm just really excited but it's
gonna be tough man yeah it's what I just
gotta see how they how they close the
deal with seasonal rivals is going to
ultimately see where it places but but
we're back to you like where where are
you at you still hold it on your square
as far as fees it of arrivals versus
without arm season of opulence
question seriously I mean oh okay so
season of opulence not gonna lie I do
love it you know it's all option of you
know it you know creating like I really
want to go for that sniper so let me
take this or that or you know making
your own weapons and getting what you
want our in season of opulence could
make as many this was before the nerf
you could make as many as you want it
correct in the beginning yes yeah now
you got brought in a lot you could farm
at a lot of belief from your one till
they patched it and I was like oh man I
can only do one now um as opposed to
this one I like something about this
season it's just more fun me know and
then with a team of six and then do the
thing and then BOOM but this one for
really bad I can have all the um brawls
and he'll still I'm still trying to get
a freaking gun role gnawing hunger I'm
just living in the UM I'm just living in
the on parole system right now and I
just well as many weapons as I won an
armor trying to finish that triumph so
that's another reason this baby's more
memorable for some reason it's just like
this season more than I you would think
I would like season of opulence more but
this one better
you might be like no you're good I love
the new mute button by the way sorry
random tangent I look like I can't
really do this I could like
look at it look at it then no that's one
of those like if somebody asked me like
hey what's something that like kind of
annoys you or sometimes you have to
fidget with it and it's like the mute
button now I'm like it's like the
littlest thing and I'm just like it's
it's just touch so there's no clicky
button it's just a nice um but no
honestly like I'm I'm just kind of
playing devil's advocate here because
this season has potential the way it
wraps cuz its building right now we're
seeing stuff like the eggshell door from
eros and I'm like what's the deal with
The Drifter and then we've got like all
the little tip and we're gonna get one
every week the evacuation and that's
okay so like what leads into the other
stuff now we have Exodus mm-hmm
now if you look up the definition of
Exodus a mass departure of people
especially immigrants like that's what
like the definition is so you go look at
a Shamir and he's got all its crates to
pack up all his crap and get the hell
out of there so what I wanted to ask you
guys is we started to do the Exodus
quest which was cool you don't go to the
four different planets go to a couple
interactions of things go to a strike on
each one stuff like that
I wanted to ask you guys as the season
wraps and I want to see kind of as your
speculation for how it's gonna go
because this is our first tease that
these people are getting out there
they're not just gonna get like blown up
but they're planning for this they know
they got a leave and something is
looming how do you think they're gonna
handle it and I wanted to kind of give
you a couple options if you get a third
feel free to throw it out there
mm one well I guess there's two
questions live event will there be a
live event involved in the Exodus and
also will they do everything at once
like well like the half of the director
go dark or is it like once a week like
towards the end of the season hey guess
what this is the last week Titans gonna
be here Sloane's packing up she's gonna
Park it next to the ball in the tower
how do you think this is gonna transpire
towards the end of the season because
we're gonna get the lure bits up and
tilled in but somehow for NPCs Asher
Vance
Sloane and Anna Bray got to go somewhere
today end up in the tower do that go off
and do Anna's probably gonna go off and
do their own thing but as Sloane gonna
Park it up as military leader next is
avala she's gonna be like side office
over there is Vance gonna go hang out in
the hangar
like where are these people all gonna
end up because there's a lot of
interesting personnel is ash you're
gonna bug the hell out of I correlate so
yeah I can see so many cool things they
could do so I wondered kind of wanted to
go plan it by playing it so Asher first
cuz that was the first one I saw he's
got his crates and stuff how do you guys
think this is all gonna transpire cheap
and cheap me what what your your guests
do you get honors on this one this is a
big topic go so good me I'm still I'm
gonna pass that I will pass that on to
oka gido okay no seriously events some
good questions about are they gonna go I
mean look I gotta say what has to be
said y'all hmm don't think they go make
really think they're all just toast I
think this is cute what they're doing
right now to fool us into thinking that
this is cool evacuation lesson remember
the great Luke Smith we are not prepared
we are not ready if they truly want to
do something that we are not ready for
let the ships already pulled up they
were here and buddy they pulled up and
didn't just kill us
right and they're scouting around
they're not shooting us down so it's got
what saves them from leaving
it's cordial right now it's very cordial
they long us into a false sense of
security
you play with our weapon oh it's a gift
it's a gift something has to give
right whether it be saboteurs
involvement something has to give ijuin
why I say that is because you make a
good point right let's just say the
optimistic side that all of them survive
right me personally I can't see all of
though these particular NPCs - Sloan
Sloan I could see somewhere in the tower
yeah right do we really see VIPs a
Shamir like a fanatic like he's crazy
yeah he's the only one but I was like
you got I mean can you imagine some of
the like chats that you could like if
you just stand with your Asher and I
Korra listening to those two go at it I
would just say I would just Park a chair
grab my popcorn and be like all right
what are we go I'm just gonna watch
those two go at it it would be hilarious
I would love it but here's the problem
here's now here's the logistical problem
Bungie got to pay more voice actors
voice audio we got when you saw she saw
Lance Anakin do that stuff in his closet
prom he's a pro he's beast is it
I would be impressed if they did it I
just can't see it logistically because
of the the actors and actresses involved
arm you know I could make maybe to you
the best I could give you is there's
like a stowaway planet where they could
just hide out cause there's a new social
zone on you're open they all go like
everyone just kind of like tells it you
got to get out of the system get out of
your system evacuation I just cannot see
a scenario again if they do it I would
love to be proven wrong we're all full
of them are in betar like regular NPCs
hey guys we'd be evacuating hey where's
my room in there cuz you're crazy
I honestly I'm wondering how the season
ends because we got a tease of al Abedin
you know the hype that that gave destiny
so how do you see a live event hand okay
so if say they don't make it or they go
off or how do you handle the live event
with four planets that's it cuz like we
stood in the tower we watched the one
I'm not gonna look in the Mariner and be
like oh this planet faded this like
that's not as cool like how does how
does it transpire somebody was actually
saying somewhere I was on the podcast I
was on last night like what if there's a
final mission it's your last time on the
planet and you got to go to that planet
and like you know help everybody finish
the last things and you're like yours is
like jumping on your ship flying out of
there as things go look there's a
there's an evacuation mission or
something with it we're bailing and we
got a controller Edison I'll give you
that I could be like jettison like gawdy
in the galaxy you know and Thor just in
space you don't say why they know but I
can't see them all in the towel that's
all I'm saying I can't see this happy
was it my picture Anna just going off
doing her thing she doesn't she doesn't
ever want to go to the tower she might
go to Europa for all I know but Vegas is
gonna be texted of Osiris where he's at
I was the advance will probably be with
those Cyrus baby might not be necessary
in the tower you know maybe maybe sir oh
I like to see some well of course
Ashur will probably kick it with Cora
since you know how they go back and
forth no talking to strong huh he told
me she don't be like it he be raising
his voice farm I'm sorry you guys all go
to the farm your level to NPCs you're
not tier 1 or tier 2 yeah I can see
swung on the farm or something like that
but he's been the farm maybe they can
make the farm cool again who knows so
we're not making hats don't start no not
make the farm cool again
oh the little farm problem problem now
here's the question
and this is what I've been wondering I'm
staring at mercury on the background of
the video mm-hmm
trials of Osiris you go to the
lighthouse on Mercury hmm not a planet
in the fall yeah how's that work by the
way yeah so this is the beacon the
lighthouse you go there and you get the
chest
that's not Mercury's not gonna be a like
accessible planet yeah this trial is
just gonna be the only thing that lands
there or I'm really curious how that
plays out yeah I don't know if you I
think for some I gotta ask bike this for
when bike was on I believe he dropped
some deep lore regarding the lighthouse
in these tombs or sounds and I thought
he said something to the effect like it
was like a darkness related it has some
disome dark I've got kind of a quote
that explains this a little bit let's go
so when you go through and you do your
Exodus missions if you read brother
Vance's texts about this I'll tell you
some Vance's studying his Scrolls when
you return so I stood snapshots of this
some glad because it's come on Osiris
the forest the pyramid he says no
connections here that go beyond simple
prophecy again tying in to everything
this season mm-hmm he stops abruptly and
then whispers in the silence as
Guardians fall in trials this lighthouse
chimes a dirge can't you hear it here in
the shadows of the pyramid the tones
have grown richer he tilts his head for
a moment his mouth held open and a smile
there there it is a song of life and
death knowing there's much to be done
you leave bands to his studies just the
idea that there is something related to
trials and like life and death and all
these things that we hear like that
there's something more to that it's
something more there is I would agree
yeah um yeah good question
they've got to figure out automatically
what happens with trials if you're still
gonna go fly out to like the planet that
either is and that's like how are they
gonna explain is the planet Lake
destroyed because it could they are like
vaulting these destinations but they're
not destroying them do all NPCs have to
leave because the pyramids make it
uninhabitable like I'm so curious that
there's so much they have to handle at
the end of the season oh oh it's I don't
know I've just been thinking so I wanted
to get you guys thoughts it's been
interesting not it's it's a great
question and I just think that um just
we still there's still a lot of mystery
with the way they handle it you know I
mean then we still got the nine yes but
you know it's a lot lot of questions I
just opened up and or
but you know I can't answer I can't
answer your thoughts I mean what would
you like to see how would you like to
see it happen do you like your reference
of like you know this goes down it'd be
cool to see even just even part of it
the next thing like you know how
bunching has been doing like live events
and with this this one I'm just curious
as to where this is gonna weigh this is
all gonna go I I don't know what's gonna
happen with mmm where are we gonna see
how where are we going to see all of
this weird of course my suggest come
from all on the farm we got plenty space
but just just all joking aside you know
so I another thing about destiny mystery
of it all yes so this is something new
David Eric's boring you know when you
look at the way at night and those life
events and now fun she's getting its
feet wet and experimenting with it and I
yeah I like to go see where it goes from
here I like to be kept in the mystery I
like to be kept you surprised some these
on things every Tuesday I want to know I
you know it's gonna go from bad to worse
cuz we already got the pyramids here
what's gonna happen next Tuesday I don't
know but I'm damn sure excited Oh
as we get closer and closer how what all
what else is right what are we where do
we literally go from here and I think
that's what you're trying to do that's
what they're that's propor for like oh
you make any mysterious season okay so
the live event can I be truthful about
the last is it talked about I just want
I was right okay i sat there and I
watched
I really like the effect of everything
how it impacted the tower and stuff and
then no but I was like really are you
are you seeing she was not impressed and
at the screen for I though I like you
know I could be like staring at the Sun
and I was first staring at the Sun then
this after it was all said and done and
then just I was like okay so piece of
the tower is gone it's just the on the
ground I was like okay I got to see the
background burning I thought well maybe
there's gonna be something cool coming
out of the ground or so I had all these
months
no after without said and done that was
it I thought the tower everything was
going to change like this right that but
this one I'm really curious now because
you know they're gonna retire those on
planets so I'm like do you know having
them do it anybody going to survive you
know who's this no that's why I'm
intrigued with this season more than I
was last one so I'm willing to bet
everybody says they hate Astra Mir I
think Asher's all are sure if you read
his Orion his lore you know he's dying
and you know he's a dying man but he
still has spirit in him I don't care too
much so something happens to smother
I want Anna let's get to Anna Anna is
awesome
you know I would be it's good she's
gonna survive she's gonna make it as
much as I didn't like the last season I
do it I did kind of like the interaction
between Zavala and her but I think it'll
be okay so bad we have a spot in the
tower I think I can see her with a big
role on the tower
absolutely I don't know but I think she
might have a big role in the tower yeah
I mean I mean the person to me who has
the strongest chance of survival of my
opinion is Anna based on her connection
to rescued and she's a star you know she
she can handle herself and we did learn
some lore in reference to we thought you
know Rasputin was a little emanating you
know it was like staph out of existence
the minute the the pyramids arrived but
we are hearing now that they kind of may
be uploaded himself potentially
somewhere as a safeguard mechanism from
what I understand so you gotta have some
back-up plan to be like yeah here I'm
gonna put myself in somebody and go take
myself somewhere he's he's gonna do
something
yeah he he's has some even though he's
been kind of taken offline he had some
kind of you know countermeasure I guess
for this event if something was that was
so he's still around my based on this
latest low when you do be the more stuff
you know I just I don't really see a
place for fames lobby let's be real like
they were very disrespectful when iris
came and they really didn't involve the
character you know I'm saying so to me
these are signs pointing to you not want
me around a sure fun story I like the
cat I would love for Asha to be around
um you know let's see you know he he
don't his choice is kind of slim I agree
with ya I don't know why Sloan gets hate
but I don't think she's that beloved in
the community for she's not like she
doesn't get hate she's just like yeah
she's like the Titan NPC she just ever
hasn't I mean she's a millage she's so
she's just the hard for a military
person yeah
and unfortunately it's not like the
British accent right the quirkiness or
the script personality it's like of the
four that we got especially in the
beginning she's just like a military
person let's do this and that's like
what she's meant to be but versus quirky
by personality and just suave space the
lowest on the totem pole
yeah when we were doing her quests she
had a very combative thing - what's
going on almost like she's going down
with the ship
on tight like nothing's gonna move her
she was very if you read her comments
it's very aggressive very you know
nothing's gonna move me like even
Cevallos like you know she she's going
right out you don't hate kind of tasks
that's the vibe I get from from Sloan
you know I'm saying and then France is
just crazy so we don't know what Bay's
gonna do this you know you know so
that's how I got bad things but the the
survival rate leading probably Anna as a
survivor getting getting to some remote
location and and then um you know
somehow getting Rasputin back in the mix
somehow you know as a back-up plan but
you know that's just gonna go hang out
with LC it could be that make sense and
a deep deep stole crap and you know who
knows what any raspy I don't hand them
Rasputin becomes like I just make him an
npc and EXO form you just hate talking
it with him shadow water to these ideas
came from podcast that was on last night
so salut
so yeah we were talking about some of
this stuff too and that's why I wanted
to bring it up today because we got to
talk and I was just like I don't know so
just like the more I think about the
more I haven't the foggiest idea which
is school because it's very it it's
gonna keep me intrigued to see how it
goes if you look at the dates of things
for the season of arrivals we've got the
calendar moments of triumph is July 7th
all the way to September 22nd
yes Soulstice of euros august 11th to
September 8th so we know that's gonna be
involved we don't know if we're going to
the European aerial zone again or
whatever we're doing you might be some
cool armor later than that because the
picture looks pretty sick so you have
September 8th when it wraps you have two
weeks left now is that just to tweak
buffers that the two-week like final
wrap-up of the season it's not like
there's four in there so it's like you
couldn't do like a weekly and now that
I'm looking at this so the last new
could be cool yeah all I can say is I'm
glad cyberpunk is not in September yes
yo salut we got Lord we got amazed we
got vibes in the ket I greet ratchet
cars I got to get Sloan she's tough but
oh yeah this is gonna be fun we love
these questions these mysteries
how does they play out but it's just so
cool to see the world change it and I
think that's the strength Arrivals has
an arai was like you said almost has a
cheat code as far as being the best
possibly the best things because we know
beyond light is come we know that every
minutes so it just it helps it's cause
you know if they tie this thing in right
no that's where I wonder is like how
will this one be viewed if it like
crushes the lead-in to beyond life it's
just gonna be it's gonna but yes you
said like the world changing now I got
the ship flying around on Io are those
gonna start like zipping around on the
other planets as we proceed forward over
the course of these weeks you know like
that's what I like about that's what I
like about this season make more
questions than answers so each Tuesday
as sucks cuz like I said I'm at work
right now
I feel like I want to go home
hurry up quit your job now I'm done
actually already played it loose right
she getting paid to do podcasts right
now I got my time
I already got my days off she's gonna be
that day one rage I get that we got this
one because this is it's got more
questions and answers so every Tuesday I
look for it when it come on work firing
up and just checking out you know
different environments to see them was
happen anything you know what's going to
happen the pyramids or sucks Paige what
what what we get some more weird
dialogue from Sloane being from other
pants I'm just right now seems chilled
and then more you know from earth
because if you notice have you noticed
like trees kind of looking go through
the silver yeah yeah doesn't it look
like there's like it's like sitting in
water basically or like a fluid kind of
yeah it looks really weird ups are
always something happening that's why
was that's why this season was more
memorable for me see fabulous yeah now
they're adding all these real time stuff
to it and you just questioning oh yes
gonna next they've raised a bar like I
think again it's early I'm trying to be
respectful to opulence I really am it's
early but it's like you said it best you
got every week II just excited what's
gonna happen next what what's this and
and you know again
guesses the Chico to be all a just
something about this season it I haven't
played this much in such a long time you
know um it's a testament to the season
you have to say and again during oblems
I was playing a must admit to but we
just got to see what's gonna happen and
it's just cool it's cool I love I will
say this last one I'll say is that what
arrivals is doing now is how I
envisioned seasons to be in the first
place yeah you know saying just that
consistent steady drip of content story
context you know there's that then we
got these cool exotics you know it's
just it's a good place it really really
isn't and the focusing with the UM rules
and and you know it's just it's just in
a good spot they they really they're
really doing if a fantastic job so far
this season to get everybody hyped and
and playing destiny consistent shots my
boy cat daddy look two quarters in here
you know he just picked up destiny he's
like calm man it feels like this is the
right time I picked this game well I got
yeah he's going hardcore like he
probably more light like to me right now
I'm seeing my casual destiny friends who
all my car bouncing hates when I call me
but like there are hardcore playing
every day like they're going past a soft
cap they're doing things and now we got
this still the season of you know did
which call the moments of triumph that's
gonna make us do these rays there's a
lot going on there's a lot go it's
really cool
let me see there you know if you know I
just look at my friends roster like okay
here's some things I haven't seen in a
long time but that's how I get from that
like this is pretty big thank you
absolutely absolutely something I'm not
gonna spoil but I'll talk to you about
it afterwards
oh now just looking into what had been a
little bit date of mine and I don't want
to do that on podcast but for what's
coming this is this is how you build up
hype so you guys got to keep tuning into
the podcast so we don't get to talk
about it you get that real
action but can't spoil it on are you
kidding I can't do that well it just
happened now it's not new it's just me
looking through clearing some things up
in my mind oh she did I don't we were
here we can talk offline that's normally
we do our little hey chat this is the
time we talk about spoilers so if you
what what happened that we have to do
like a little dog this doesn't feel like
the right time my save this right here I
need a one inch at if you want to do a
little spoiler talk I need a 2 inch at
right you guys if you guys want to save
it for later one for yes two words two
for note who thought it was the crystal
one big one re Dakota says - we like the
code show robot says what Dan says 100
mil mental wonder what's waiting so far
EEP are amazed says 102 come on now stop
it whiskey look I'm sorry are you
Colleen it's leaning guys it's okay fair
warning the next time I do this
yes boilers will be over so spoilers in
five seconds if you don't want to hear
about them check has spoken so we got to
do it alright everybody ready we're
going 5 4 3 2 1
that's Katie
so this is from the date of mine steps
of Exodus this is related to the
travelers chosen mm-hmm the sidearm that
we don't actually have officially
announced yet but we do know the name of
travelers chosen from one of the
triumphs so we do know that already
officially in-game mmm-hmm
then the steps of the quests that we did
Exodus as you go through the four
planets that's all we've got officially
in-game what comes next that next that
has been data mined evacuation quest
steps literally says evacuation summons
from Zavala evacuation io you go to a
loss sector you go to an adventure you
go to a strike and then evacuation Titan
go do a loss sector go to a strike go do
go to the solarium and then we'll report
back to Sloane lingo banks is avala go
to mercury evacuate so it literally goes
through each planet hitting it adventure
so Mercury's go see the infinite forest
you go to the tree availability strike
so you kill in some on each planet you
go evacuation is the name of these
missions and it says report back to the
valla
fly to the tower chat was avala letting
him know you've evacuated each planet to
the best of your ability
but he'll give you your new exotic
sidearm so those are the steps so we are
in theory we're gonna try at least now
is this do you think gonna be the same
way it went down this week where it's
like hey you go from one to the next to
the neckline one day like the whole
thing goes live what do you think
they're gonna start space in these
evacuations that'd be like hey go to the
Volta this week hey go in vacua ty oh
sorry I'm waving my hands no yeah yeah
look I say quickly the number twos are
upset but I say they gotta stretch it a
little bit you know I'm saying based on
the length of the season there's a
potential they do what they doing now
right which is the question as to weeks
or some goddamn we go around but like I
said people ain't gonna make it y'all
I'm telling y'all some people they go
maybe the pyramids don't hold up they
don't pull yeah so I mean I don't know
Chiti will you add evacuation that's the
name of this yeah askin
chaotic comes like okay I'm ready to get
out of here go get so you know go to IO
you gotta go go gotta go to Titan then
we gotta go to mercury you know you get
on here and get out oh my god why does
this all remind me of a frickin movie
all this I can't just like you know if
you're doomed if you stay here you know
hurry I don't know it's gonna and go I
can't wait for evacuation hey dude as a
guardian you know it's like generally
this does meet brother Vance on Mercury
tell'em Zavala has ordered him to
evacuate me meet Anna Brae on Marsteller
Zavala has ordered her to evacuate like
that's like our gave the thing we know
some of them ain't gold they go go down
with the ship cool I don't see phase
leaving my house he told for daddy cool
I kiss he's I wanna stuff with it I
can't see huh so sure I was gonna say
shout out to trams in chat who says the
Vance isn't gonna go lock himself in the
infinite forest I could see that yeah
see that I could totally see his crazy
self doing that and he see Anna saying
wake she goes you know she loved her son
big red cuz she went to leave red like
that cuz sister though but red she's
tired to ask you if but what if she
takes Rasputin with her in the
evacuation like into an EXO take you
with me and then we're gonna go like
find your home over on your hope of the
new in the new home if it's hot but she
like our whole family history is tied to
Bray's like the recipe she's gonna be
fine this is gonna be okay he happy the
home for her in Europe yeah they'll be
fine probably will be like hanging out
with Savalas some way or another that
one I can see but a sure he's that I'll
be curious where he let me curious yeah
I don't know how he gonna play it yeah
he's a wild card he so he's all over the
place he won't give a hands to them yeah
okay we're done all spoilers are done I
write like an idiot right now but we are
spoilers go to you that was that was
that was that as a heavy hitter right
there so was so yeah again all of the
narrative implications of the season
building into beyond light losing
planets vaulting stuff it's man like I
accept him we can't get here soon enough
and somebody said that in chat and I
100% agree that being said as a guy who
wants to play about four of their games
before September gets here I'm gonna be
okay if it's like here's your weekly
story mission here's these things go to
your moments and when you're done I can
play these three other games that I want
to play because I'm waiting on ghost of
Tsushima Horizons like yeah I can't wait
on those two but you can oh man dude the
fall
gonna be crazy in this game Luke said
not prepared remember those words I mean
when I hit at man the possibilities
I'm just saying get ready get ready
pretty mix I think they're gonna end
some of them get ready telling this what
we wasn't ready for forsaken when
certain things happen September
September is always a good point
hmm always epic always so but I guess
that I so September was when they you
know have you done big things mm-hmm
would they kill people off in a season
though not an expansion because you just
really because you're like four seconds
win oh yeah so like do they do it in a
season I got it I got a they cliff they
do it like how if you remember one of
our biggest fun is podcast the biggest
point of contention you ever had was the
trailer before it's forsaken can we're
pissed because you would like they
showed Kate died before he should have
happened in the game remember well that
I agree that still like that hey and
remember think about this they even know
we've got this teaser they've still got
a promote beyond light right a couple of
weeks out oh and you can't just run the
same when they run we already see like
would we finish solstice of heroes
that's those last two weeks have got to
be like hard marketing for beyond late
if not before that but the marketing
push remember when we I know you hated
it at the time I still do I know you do
change I respect you from a lore and
surprised and I'm on your side with that
it would have been it would have hit it
would have hit different if we just saw
okay dying game and nobody knew that was
gonna happen
yeah that's like the last of a spoilers
going in right kind of boy no I'm with
you I feel you on that
but for marketing for the casuals do you
know how many people was like your I
played this they kill mommy oh no we got
to go get Aldrin we got to get the bear
it was a he served its purpose-to selves
a sister fell begs me I give that yeah
but unfortunately marketing shouldn't
beat up narrative if you really want to
stick to it you know which one this but
each serve its purpose even though we
didn't agree with the choice you know
say necessarily I don't know how you you
felt you liked in that regard but you
know III think they got they got to do
something epic to mark this before
September and so what do you say Jimmy
what do you say
oh no I'm with you they need to do
something dynamic email to sell us on
this and you know on the subject of
older it he might have a this is the
question for you guys you think you
might know anytime we got to see him was
when we did the thing for Petra you
think you'll have some kind of
appearance I know why there anything or
already we just like okay just gonna
bump him off and just people guessing
cuz I would like to see him anyway I
would love to have a part something is
this awful night fighting good but I'm
sitting here thinking about Aldrin man
and how his memories have been a nose
hast everything so you probably don't
remember but I would love to see him
have a part something anything that's
not my real quest which is this about
Willie's doors but I already have an
idea I mean so my current working theory
is dreaming city and tangled tour but
mostly the dreaming city is still in the
game yes if anything is gonna happen
with the dreaming city it's gonna be
fall of 2021 related to the witch queen
expansion and that tie in because you've
got apparently shadows on that's still
gonna be around for a while doing its
thing shattered throne is with Dolan
karu and that three week cycle at some
point that's hopefully got to get
resolved for their sake because the
awoken are just stuck in this crap loop
right and there she's the one who's part
of that with well in Carew potentially
being powered up we still don't know if
that's even true most things seventh who
does or says our you know take them to a
grain of salt because they all could be
false but if that's the tie-in I think
that might be the point where if Sabbath
Newton's is big of a villain potentially
or as powerful as sweet sue she could
potentially be that's when we're going
to need somebody at the scale of Mara
sauvé has to come back so my hunch is
older in Mara saw of somewheres towards
like maybe Aldrin comes back in season
15 the one who leads into the witch
queen that's where I would see that
coming in of course that leaves him in
limbo for like nine more months which ko
sucks but I feel that's how that would
all tie together best that's me what
about you is um let me jump in I think
you're right because as much as Aldrin
has been put off and we all want to see
him right we all want to know what the
reactions gonna be
I think there's just too many story
threads right now to give his story the
proper attention in context it needs to
be fleshed out properly so I would agree
your light has got to be where we go
with this you know what was the going to
deep stone [ __ ] we know stone crypt for
the rain though wasn't Aramis you know
I'm saying falling houses the fallen are
coming back together and all that so I
just I don't know if he really fits that
I mean listening he come me pull up
people up here's how he gonna be bad but
you know I think yeah I think you're
right I think he has to be spaced out
away from this because we gotta know the
secret so to keep we got number this
lets me real the stranger we have a see
stranger so long so she's got to get
fleshed out we have you know say like to
me this is her season right this is this
is like yo we haven't seen you since d1
like we got to get answers what's going
on why are you why is this meeting of
the minds with these weird you know
strange characters that shouldn't have a
lot in common
but we're ready for the darkness so yeah
I think
you outstanding you got to stop acting
evil a party if solvent dude I've done
with him oh if anything that's gonna be
who's the ever verse lady oh I was gonna
say anything against s she's one of the
trickster stealing all our money able
Avanti is just a nice old lady who runs
our events that's she's she's not bad
I'm call a season 15 season of
redemption
mm-hmm-hmm oh well which oh it's gonna
be fun it's going for a kid again the
last thing too is we forget you know
some major players with the Vanguard and
you know remember st. is now here
permanently we got to see his involved
things you know it's the possibilities
of summer flat but I do agree to me I
think there's just too many characters
right now to do his story you know I'm
saying like I think like this like a
little mini infinity war we gotta do his
little separate you know a little story
his own little separate movie in another
season prior you know what is it I
always mess up the name Scott he's not
scarlet Queens it's a Jewish Queen yes
you get so bad we keep if you say
Scarlet Witch we're gonna get dem seed
by Disney so please don't combine those
we're gonna get the podcast shut down
but I got this gonna be fun I can't wait
there's gonna be fun we still got no it
was cold
cats he's out of here he's driving away
leviathans Audi the gold large is no
longer gonna be on necess when you like
sirs gonna go back up in his tree where
is there gonna be on Europa like cuz now
that we're losing a lot of the base
planet player Lisa were losing two of
the base plants Resort can arrive he's
got his
did you see the UM the thing in the
prophecy dungeon about the nine and
emissary yes yeah okay yeah I saw okay I
want to talk about it a nine-day
emissary like the music that stuff no
but that was anybody to chandu what I'm
talking about if it's in their dungeon
you can say it like yeah emissary
talking from like her former awoken
itself telling us almost not to trust
them they are undecided or something in
regards to the nine did you see that
who's not decided like the nine basic
you don't have to be vague just say it
like if it was a privacy dungeon it was
into the affair I mean I saw this on yes
Oren as Oren that's her I believe her
name okay I found out to Chris right
there was some dialogue when you in the
actual forest I mean the the desert yep
when um you know all the planets these
are ones that's gonna be going away yeah
prophesize oh yeah the names right great
maze know what I'm talking about yes so
she's almost on some talking from her
regular name like yo don't trust the
nine that's the vibe I'm getting now
there's some weirdness going on but she
broke character like is something going
on to telling out right now but not I
don't know if they all the way to be
trusted with this situation either we
know very little about them at all so
that'll be interesting do that dungeon
don't do that there's a lot of questions
that's illegal but yes there's
everything here we do your wigglies this
week before is it because there's a lot
of clues yes and the law has been
excellent in tabs in this the first
season I really would I get a peaceful
I'm like diving right it by yeah we go
see amazing I'll trust him and ups there
man I don't know yeah they they look at
spooky
they look he's spooky a video no it's a
crystal coming in with the lore alright
here we go Horan who was a sunbreaker
Titan who wielded the mall would you
got back for all titans the burning mall
is Oren's mmm interesting we gotta see
yeah they are a wild card yeah it's like
somewhere I remember like the nine in
and of themselves aren't overly powerful
they may be like more all-knowing or
omniscient or anything like that but
they're not per se gonna be at a scale
of the darkness or Sabbath oon they may
be weird like observers of everything
that kind of goes on and they may have
like wagers and maybe steer sides but
they're I don't think per se they're a
big worry are they to be trusted who
knows but I don't think there's much
gonna be like a giant villain
the question becomes what role are they
playing in this you know I'm saying in
general and in relationship to the
darkness and a whole bunch of stuff it
it's very it's a weird weird dynamic
with them and then they're helping us to
give us weapons they don't buy very very
strange very strange relationship it's
like the pyramids want to talk with us
but then we've got Sabbath une trying to
stop that so what's up with the pyramids
how truly evil are they just the yin to
the yang of the traveller versus the
darkness do you just need to pick a side
versus they're just being one side
mm-hmm I mean go wander down very deep
dark paths of the lore in this game
which is really really cool but yeah
they seem to be opening a lot more doors
than giving us answers right now which
builds to cool stuff but yeah there's a
lot we don't know
ton ton trying to find that thing I was
gonna say is there anything else related
to this week but I've missed I feel like
we talked a lot but we also kind of got
off on some tangents Oh as destiny for
you Oh No yeah yeah we don't know if
everybody knows but yeah podcast used to
be called flashpoint in theoretically
flashpoint would be kind of quick our
joke is that always be long point
because we'd go so long it was never
clear goodness oh it seems to be there
was a lot of nice art the art showcase
of people with different well got all
the art emblems that was really cool and
I liked a lot of those I will say one
shout out to me was the plush ribbon
someone made that was so good I thought
that was so hilarious that's that one's
awesome I would buy one in a heartbeat
mm-hmm yeah go check out the Bungie
store go check out the tuam make a
donation get your little heart emblem
and your heart dosed which is just so
cute not yet I tried I couldn't looking
you right hand someone
that but I want that mask yeah I can't
ask ya at the bunch alright she's making
some money
alright oh says to me Oren says trust
what you see on your peril trust what
you hear on your peril including
anything you hear from this voice why
she breaking protocol she's supposed to
be the emissary like that that's the
part that's confusing like why is she
talking from from this perspective
oculus of lies she no longer the MSA
like what's going on hmm
oh it all it is it's weird this lot of
stuff was going to be coming out I can't
wait yeah and that even well what is it
like I said this is week five
it's seasonal we haven't even we have
39.99 lore entries left to go I think
cuz there's 14 then it's like a 15 week
season or something it's we got a ways
to go
yeah it's a fact that is effect and I
did you see the fashion show oh yeah
[Music]
to the answer but III got other big
stuff coming so see I'm believe it's big
secret
yeah gonna say like as we wrap up do you
want to let in let them know of any
teases of stuff you got coming or just
stay tuned on the Twitter's what do you
got
everybody find you what's the what's the
best place we hide me y'all know me I'm
always on Twitter every every day
because I work so I'm with my computer
my Twitter's is always open is there
calm for its last chibi Kim is best
won't find me there and you know I'm
also on the twitches as you kids call it
but I'm also on twitch twitch that TV
for its last chibi Kim s gaming schedule
is a little off because I work Monday
through Fridays so I usually come home
and I probably might start streaming
late-night probably about 8 o'clock
central begins definitely free
afternoons noon til whenever I'm tired
but yeah that's where you'll find me and
me there on twitter and twitch resolute
one herself
[Laughter]
thank you for having me I have a blast
this is this podcast in the morning and
I only loved it breakfast around the
campfire I'm glad you were able to share
all this extra Risa giving me some more
on emissary law actually I mean they
believe many things that you need to
hear but for all their power there are
no less fallible than tower consensus
meaning mmm it was something that effect
year like it was she was dropping to
shopping jewels manager job jeweled is
it steep I can't wait this is this is
gonna play the prophecy dungeon until I
hear this one the
got a plate I gotta play it again but
Louis I'm gonna pull my hair out so that
one happens always watching you brother
Howser actually working on it I got to I
had a really stupid death on the boss
phase like solo I know I'll eventually
get there I just got to put a good boss
phase together but flawless man that's
gonna take some practice because there's
a lot of I did the cube room like on my
third try when my brother had to go do
something and then I tried this time and
it took a lot longer saw a flaw flawless
is I'm gonna have to get some practice
in before that one even the attempts
start trying just run and solo over and
over just to get it used to it you
inspired me just to farm my last wish
Ray chest so I can get those damn taking
our own movies those are really really
helpful and now they actually dropped it
if you do a solo you get a ghost and if
you do a flawless you get a sparrow both
of which are very cool and if you do the
solo floss you'll just get both of them
so you don't have to do a solo flawless
but if you finish it solo you get a cool
ghost it's like it's like a neon rabbit
go look it up it's actually really
really go go get some solo practice a
dungeon is dungeons awesome yeah well
Cognito what are you got coming up sir
my lord of the round table blends it
around yeah you already know so first of
all again salute cha Chi beaver coming
through absolutely fun yes I'm so proud
actually ah today like we're the first I
guess you know like that's that cool
sake we could say that we could say that
Wow so very proud very cool story
awesome oh yeah for me at Lord kaan bean
or Twitter you already know what it is
Iowa podcast every Sunday 1:00 p.m.
Eastern on YouTube or twitch is the
Lord's Day big guests this week we will
have on the principal programmer of
gears tactics so just set me
nevah dia and he has worked on a lot of
stuff he's works at armies
Splash Damage so he's done the PC port
from that he's worked on games there you
go there he's worth doing games like all
Batman Arkham the Gears of War franchise
he's armed
tons of franchise Wolfenstein you know
so Splash Damage is a company on the
rise they not only do they have the own
Eyed Peas
they actually also arm helped on a lot
of the bigger games that come out so
that'll be this Sunday we'll have them
in the realm so come check that out
we'll also talk about gaming all the
latest Sony deals with Epic Games and
many Xbox with WP get it's a lot going
on ya know it's like I'm the fall is the
fault in the holidays man I there's not
gonna be enough time to do any of this
stuff that we want to do things your
gamer yes if you're a gamer yeah that's
why I was so happy cyberpunk I'll take
yeah let me get my destiny month or two
in there because I'm gonna need it
exactly but of course yeah please
support Lords of gaming net really
appreciate all the support for the
articles all that stuff and yeah that's
what I got is what I got what about what
about Julie uh so for me first off shout
out to my Chrono Trigger sister that is
yeah you're honestly inspiring me to try
and get get my get my playthrough in
there at some point I want to keep going
back through it again but I'm always so
busy with other stuff but I know you've
reinvigorated me to try and get this
going and on top of that so shout out
thank you had a blast so much fun I'm
glad we made it work in glad hey work is
uh pressing your real hard so you can do
a podcast with us from from the office
from the corner executive office we made
that happen
loaded yeah for me to know where to find
me
I bought this everywhere you guys know
twitch Twitter YouTube be working on who
knows what in this game most likely
until next Friday on the 17th ghosts
come out so I'll be working to try and
get through that one but also next week
our guests it is gonna be Zoe T TV so
she's actually Cherie when right now so
we are gonna go raid Zoe say hey to her
so hang out and chat as we wrap this
thing up I'll send you guys over so you
can say hey to our guest who's gonna be
on next week so she's over in onus at UK
so she's across the pond so she'll be
joining us for a nice afternoon campfire
but breakfast for us but yeah honestly
thank you guys it's been awesome chat
you guys have been on fire so thank you
for hanging out with us so make sure you
go send some love over to so as soon as
we wrap up
we will raid you guys over there but for
man it's been an amazing episode 111
continue climbing it's been awesome so
July 10th chibi thank you very much
it has been awesome Cockney know as
always
look Oh the co-host of greatness here
appreciates Bravo thank you guys so for
this episode it has been